[Music]
perhaps the most startling finding for
meditation and beginners comes with
what's called compassion or
loving-kindness meditation this is a
practice that often accompanies the
mindfulness of the breath for example
people will do at the end of a session
they bring to mind people who have been
kind to them they think of themselves
they think of people they love people
they know everyone everywhere and wish
them well that may they be safe happy
healthy free from suffering and it turns
out that the repetition of those phrases
is psychoactive it actually changes the
brain and how you feel right from the
get-go we find for example the people
who do this meditation who've just
started doing it actually are kinder
they're more likely to help someone in
need they're more generous and they're
they're happier it turns out that the
brain areas that help us or that make us
want to help someone that we care about
also connect with the circuitry for
feeling good so it feels good to be kind
and all of that shows up very early in
just a few hours really of total
practice of loving-kindness or
compassion meditation so we feel that
the the brain is somehow biologically
prepared to learn to look better the
brain area that becomes stronger and its
activity is the same as a parent's love
for a child it's the mammalian
caretaking circuitry it's seen it we
share it with all other mammals and in
humans it's extremely important for the
third of three kinds of empathy there's
empathy that allows you to understand
better how someone thinks to take their
perspective that should be a good
communicator
there's the empathy where you connect
emotionally you feel what the other
person feels immediately you sense in
your own body what's going on in the
other person
this allows rapport chemistry it's also
very important but the third kind
empathy is what's called empathic
concern it's the feeling of caring about
another person wanting to help them it's
the basis of compassion you can have the
first two and not be particularly
concerned or caring but if you have all
three then you've got the whole package
of empathy and we find that
loving-kindness meditation strengthens
that third both in terms of how you
behave how you feel and and what's
happening in the brain one of the
paradoxes we found when we started
looking very closely at all of the
research that's done on meditation was a
kind of a disconnect between what the
classic traditions from which these
methods come our saying is important and
what scientists are studying one of the
most important things whether you're
looking in the Christian literature or
the Buddhist literature or Jewish
literature Hindu literature doesn't
matter all of the meditative traditions
within those classical schools of
thought are saying the most important
thing is that you become less focused on
yourself
caring only about yourself less selfish
as it were and more open to the needs of
others more compassionate more caring
more present to other people and even
though the classic traditions say this
is what counts in terms of the
scientific interest it was minimal we
found maybe three or four studies that
remember out of 6,000 that really were
tight methodological II and spoke to
this but here again the news was good if
you look at longer term meditators
people who have done more than say one
or two thousand hours of meditation over
their entire life and this happens
naturally you know let's say you do a
half hour sit every morning before you
go out for the day well after a decade
or two it does add up and it it seems
that that cumulative amount does make
people less selfish less just caring
about me and more open to other people
around them more
more caring more able to tune in more
able to empathize and this also shows up
in a brain change which we think is
quite significant which is that the
nucleus accumbens which is the focus of
craving of you know I gotta have that
drug addiction for example it becomes
actually become smaller in longer term
meditators and this seems to be related
to this lack of I me mine in how people
behave and how they think in their
emotional life and we see it most
strikingly of course in Olympic level
meditators where these are people who
have done 10,000 or more 10,000 62,000
hours of meditation and they are
genuinely selfless people but they're
very nourishing very enjoyable to be
with because they pay attention to you
they really focus on the person they're
with and how they can be of service or
what do you need now is very refreshing
[Music]